is a Demon Slayer Prodigy he is the
youngest known hashirai in history and
he has a secret family connection to the
strongest demon Moon upper rank 1
kokushi bowl by the end of this video
you will learn everything you need to
know about muichiro's tragic backstory
his incredible powers and abilities and
his shocking connection to both the
strongest demon moon and the strongest
Demon Slayer the Mist hashira muichiro
tokito is only 14 years old when we
first meet him in the story that means
that he's actually a few years younger
than tanjiro and yet he's already a
hashira but despite his unbelievable
talent and Incredible family lineage
muichiro had a very unremarkable
childhood he grew up in the woods in the
middle of nowhere with a twin brother
named yuichiro the two boys were the
sons of a humble Woodcutter and his wife
at the age of 10 the boy always
tragically lost their mother to
pneumonia and then they lost their
father too around the same time he had
gone out to pick medicinal herbs for
their sick mother during a storm and he
slipped and fell off a cliff so the two
ten-year-old twins suddenly found
themselves living alone as orphans deep
in the woods in the middle of nowhere
yuichiro was the older brother and after
the tragic passing of their parents he
developed a very cynical Outlook online
he thought that their father was a fool
for going out in a storm just to try to
save their mother's life she was already
too far gone for some herbs to save her
and had their father just stayed home
that night then only their mother would
have died instead of both of them
muichiro was more compassionate and
sentimental and he disagreed with his
brother's Grim outlook on life the
following year when the brothers were
around 11
oyakatasama's wife came to visit them at
their home she told them that they were
descend of legendary Swordsmen and that
their ancestor was the original user of
the breath of the sun she wanted the two
of them to become demon Slayers but
yuichiro turned her away he had no
intention of risking his life or the
life of his brother just to help
complete strangers because if they were
foolish enough to do that then they
would end up just like their father
yuichiro believed that the demon Sayers
just wanted to use him and his brother
for their own selfish ends and he didn't
trust the Demon Slayer core truth be
told he didn't really trust anyone and
he refused to carelessly throw away his
own life for someone else's sake then
one night a demon found their home and
attacked them yuichiro was Gravely
injured by the demon attack and after
witnessing this something snapped inside
muichiro he used his wood cutting axes
and every other tool at his disposal to
cut the demon up and Crush parts of his
body with heavy rocks pinning him down
on until the sun came up and killed him
when he finally returned to the house
muichiro found his brother praying to
the gods and Buddhas to spare muichiro's
life because unlike yuichiro muichiro
has a kind heart and he wants to help
others yuichiro regretted that he
prevented his brother from helping other
people because his brother was special
and kind and he wanted to fight for the
good of others unfortunately yuichiro's
wounds were too severe and soon after he
died in his brother's arms when
oyakatasama's wife returned once again
to the tokito family home she was able
to heal muichiro and save his life
muichiro then joined the Demon Slayer
core and he decided to fight to save
others from the demons but the trauma
that he experienced blocked out most
memories of his former life as a result
of his prestigious lineage and
incredible natural Talent muichiro's
speedran the demons player ranks and he
became a hashira only two months after
joining up like that is just freaking
insane I mean yes muichiro was blessed
with a legendary bloodline and
extraordinary natural talent but that
still seems insanely fast anyway to
impart to the trauma and memory loss
that muichiro experienced after the
tragic death of his brother muigiro's
personality began to resemble that of
his older brother yuichiro instead of
his own usual compassionate and
idealistic self luigiro became more cold
than indifferent much like yuichiro used
to be he also felt a deep-seated anger
towards the demons and this is what
drove him to keep surpassing his limits
and all possible expectations in order
to destroy as many demons as possible
when we first meet muichiro in the story
his personality is much closer to
yuichiro's than to his own which is why
he initially comes off as such a cold
and blunt person quick warning right now
I'm gonna start talking about muichiro's
many powers and abilities and in order
to do that properly I have to spoil some
elements of the swordsmith village Arc
and Beyond please proceed with caution
you have been warned
in terms of power it should already be
clear by now that muichiro is an
absolute Prodigy and a once in a
lifetime Talent it only took him two
months of training to become a hashira
at such a young age even though before
this he never even practiced with a
sword so the natural Talent is just off
the wall muichiro unlocks his Demon
Slayer Mark during the swordsmith
village Arc and after that he is able to
defeat and kill upper Moon 5 gyoko on
his own the vast majority of upper Moon
fights are Team battles with multiple
hashira and or demon Slayers engaging
the demon all at once but muigiro just
solos upper Moon 5 which again speaks to
how special he is eventually muichiro
also gains access to the transparent
world and his nichidin blade turns
bright red he goes on to play a crucial
role in ultimately defeating upper Moon
one kokushible who is of course a direct
ancestor of muigiro during that fight it
is revealed that is a descendant of
kokuchibo through his children the
children that kokushibu abandoned once
he decided to join the Demon Slayer core
and even though the family's surname
changed over the centuries kokushibu
abandoned his children something like
450 years ago so it's been quite a while
kokushibu can still sense that muichiro
tokito is a descendant of his own
tsugikuni family muichiro is like the
great great great great great great
grandson of
michikasutsukikuni also known as upper
Moon one kokushibo and I'll be honest I
have no idea just how many greats I
needed to include there so I'm just
winging it the fact that muichiro is a
direct descendant of kokuchibo means
that he is also directly related to
kokushipo's twin brother yorichi the
strongest Demon Slayer in history and I
guess that makes sense when you think
about it the only person in the story
with more natural Talent than muichiro
is yorichi so the fact that they are
descended from the same bloodline isn't
too much of a surprise during their
fight kokushibu notices the extent of
muichiro's skill and talent and he is
proud of his descendant and he even
wishes for his descendant to become a
demon so that he would have all of
eternity to keep getting stronger as
expected wichita's senses reflexes speed
strength endurance and stamina are at
the highest of levels and on top of that
he is of course a master swordsman who
uses missed breathing to destroy his
opponents missed breathing is a
derivative of wind breathing and it
mimics the properties of mist it has
seven known forms including first form
low clouds distant Haze which is a
thrusting attack second form eight
layered Mist which involves a barrage of
eight slashes one on top of the other
third form scattering Mist Splash a
circular slash with the power to blow
away enemy projectiles fourth form
shifting flow slash which includes a
rapid slash right as the sword is pulled
from its Scabbard fifth form sea of
clouds and Haze which involves the user
running at the enemy at high speed and
following through with a barrage of
slashes sixth form lunar dispersing Mist
which involves the user leaping into the
air and raining down a large number of
slashes on his enemies and finally
seventh form obscuring clouds which is a
technique that allows the user to
confuse his enemies by Shifting the
tempo of his movements in a way that
tricks the opponent's eyes this form was
created by muichiro himself and yet
another spoiler alert in the rest of the
video I will be discussing what
ultimately happens with muichiro in the
final arcs of the Demon Slayer story so
if that is something you don't want to
find out right now I am giving you
another fair warning in order to fully
explain the true nature of muturo's
character I really have to talk about
his entire character Arc so Major
Spoilers ahead
okay now that everyone who doesn't want
to know the ultimate fate of muichiro is
presumably gone let's talk about the
final fight that we see him
participating in the fight against upper
Moon one kokushible which along with
muichiro also includes genya sanami and
gyome muichiro is actually the first to
meet kokushibo and as soon as he sees
upper Moon one mucho can tell right away
that he is different from all the other
demon moons kokushibu has a magnificent
and Majestic presence and he is clearly
a master swordsman which leads muichiro
to conclude that kokushibu was once a
Demon Slayer upper Moon one's Aura is so
intimidating that muichiro's body shakes
and he feels like his body is refusing
to fight which is something that he's
never experienced before
kokushibu then casually asks for the
young hashira's name uichiro identifies
himself and kokusuba responds by saying
his own human name was michikatsu
tsugikuni even though their family names
are different kokushibu can tell that
muichiro is a direct descendant of his
own child and therefore a direct
descendant of him as well
ouijito is surprised to hear this but
nonetheless he summons up the courage
and strength to calm his nerves and
prepare for battle so much so that
kokushibu Praises his spiritual strength
and ability to calm himself so quickly
wichiro then starts his attack on
kokushibu using missed breathing but at
first he's unable to land a hit even so
kokushiboy is impressed by muichiro's
strength and courage especially since he
can tell that muichiro is still only a
14 year old at this point in the story
kokushibu also notices that the Demon
Slayer Mark has now appeared on
muigiro's face and as muichiro continues
to use impressive techniques against the
demon kokushibu concludes that it would
be rude if he didn't draw his own sword
and so kokushibon unleashes his own
breathing style Moon breathing the very
first swing of kokuchipo's moon
breathing slices off muichiro's left
hand and muichiro is stunned to learn
that kokushibo can use a breathing
technique even after becoming a demon
muichiro quickly makes a tourniquet from
his shirt and just keeps on fighting
almost like nothing happened this is an
absolutely mind-boggling level of
discipline strength and courage he loses
an arm he instantly acts to stop the
bleeding and then he just keeps fighting
this is why muichiro became a hashira at
such a young age age aside he is a
magnificent Warrior through and through
kokushi boy is so moved by the strength
and determination of his descendant that
he doesn't even want to kill him anymore
instead he says that he will ask muzan
to turn muichiro into a demon that is
when genya shows up and enters The Fray
he attempts to sneak up on kokushi boy
and shoot him from behind but the demon
easily spots him and uses his
unbelievable speed to just slice Kenya
up into pieces however to kokokushipa's
surprise genya is still alive and before
he can finish Kenya off the demon is
then also attacked by the wind hashira
sanami sonemi vows to make kukushimo pay
for slicing up his little brother and
after kokushibu draws his sword we
witness a fierce battle between wind
breathing and moon breathing after a
while the strongest hashira of this
entire generation the stone hashirag
himejima also joins the fight and so the
final showdown between three hashira and
genya versus upper moonwalk really gets
going while the fight between Moon
breathing and stone breathing rages The
Unbelievable wonderkid bleichiro who up
to this point had been pinned down after
being pierced by a sword pulls the sword
out of his own chest with his bare hands
just imagine what kind of unfathomable
strength and stamina it takes for a 14
year old kid to be able to push through
so much pain just to free himself and
keep fighting Wichita knows that he is
dying from blood loss but he is
determined to do something useful in
this important Battle Before He departs
this world so he does his best to wrap
his wounds and stop the bleeding and
then he helps genya put his own mangled
body back together although both genya
and muichiro are gravely injured they
vowed to keep fighting until the very
end showing just what absolute mad Lads
they both are Kenya then consumes some
of kokushibu's hair and eventually some
of his sword and as ganya and Witcher
are trying to pick themselves up from
the ground and rejoin the fight gyoma
and sanami are tag teaming kokushibo in
a desperate attempt to take his head and
defeat him luigiro finally rejoins The
Fray when he steps in to save Sunami
from one of kokushibu's attacks and then
determined to help while he is still
able to move muichiro attacks cohoshibo
while kokushibu is distracted by attacks
from gyome and sonemi muichiro manages
to move close enough to pierce
kokushibu's torso with his sword
muichiro loses one of his legs in the
process but as expected from this kid he
doesn't even care he has completely
accepted death and all he wants to do
now is be as useful as possible before
he dies in these moments muichiro shows
more courage and strength than even the
strongest of fully grown adult Warriors
and he deserves all the respect for how
valiantly he behaves during this fight
despite his young age ultimately
muichiro makes the decision to protect
gyome and sonami at all costs so that
they will survive and be able to
contribute to the final battle against
muzan he is so determined to help defeat
kokushiba before he dies that his
nitroen blade turns bright red and this
newly transformed blade causes such pain
to kokucible that he is actually
paralyzed on top of that a dying genya
uses his blood demon art to manifest a
tree around kokucible helping to keep
him immobile long enough for sanami and
yomei to take his head at first it looks
like kokushiba's power is so great that
even losing his head to a Nigerian blade
cannot defeat him to everyone's absolute
shock and Terror he is able to
regenerate even his head but this second
head looks nothing like a human head it
is a monstrous demonic head and when
kokusa catches a glimpse of his own face
he is disgusted he can't believe that he
allowed his fear of defeat to take away
his humanity and turn him into such a
monster so as kokushibu is having this
massive crisis of conscience his body
begins to break apart in the very place
that muichiro had stabbed him he is then
finished off by gyome and sonami and
thus upper Moon one kokushibol Falls in
battle Genia and muichiro both die from
the wounds that they sustained during
this grueling battle and as muichiro's
life leaves his body kyome thanks him
from the bottom of his heart because it
is thanks to muichiro that they were
able to defeat upper Moon one kokushibu
kyome says that for someone so young
muichiro was magnificent to the very end
and he vows to defeat muzon before
telling muichiro that he can now rest in
peace as he leaves this life for the
next muichiro meets his twin brother
yuichiro once again a crying yuichiro
asks his brother why he chose to die
fighting at such a young age when he
could have run away and lived a long
life but Wichita says that he could
never abandon his comrades he was happy
when he was with his friends and
comrades he had good times with them and
thanks to them he was able to smile
again crying the two brothers Embrace
each other and that is how muichiro's
life ends this particular life in the
end muichiro didn't live up to the
expectations of his ancestor kokushibo
because he refused to become a demon
like him but he definitely did live up
to the legacy of his other ancestor
kokushibu's twin brother
yorichitsuhikuni yorichi also refused to
become a demon and he lived and fought
honorably and valiantly until the very
end just like muichiro we can say with
confidence that without the unparalleled
courage strength and determination of
muichiro kokushiba would not have been
defeated and if kokushibo had survived
it's likely that muzan would never have
been defeated at all the remaining demon
Slayers gave everything they had in the
final fight against muzon and if at that
time muzan had backup from a still
living kukushi ball the demon stairs
would have lost and muzon would have won
put simply the final and most important
Battle of the entire series The Showdown
with muzon would have almost certainly
ended in Failure if not for the noble
sacrifice made by the Mist hashira
muichiro tokito what did you guys think
of this once in a lifetime Talent the
Wonder kid muichiro tokito and his
tragic sacrifice who is your favorite
hashira of all time and where does
muichiro rank on that list if you're
looking for another epic Demon Slayer
video to watch right now don't miss my
full length video on muichiro's ancestor
and the strong longest Demon Slayer in
history yorichi link in the description
and on screen if you enjoyed this video
and you want to see more demonster
content in the future leave a quick like
right now and if you're one of the over
50 of people who watch our videos but
still haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a big favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification Bell to turn on
all notifications